- Hey guys, welcome.
Thank you for joining this session,
and we are gonna spend the
next roughly 15 minutes
talking about Karpenter
and its great features
that will actually help
you achieve cost efficiency
and make your setup
really adaptive at scale.
So before we start,
I would actually want to
ask you a quick question.
How much of you guys
are using Karpenter today in production?
Perfect, amazing.
And keep your hands up
those who use it for
managing Spot Instances.
Amazing, perfect.
Thank you for sharing.
So, my name is Alexey,
I'm a Co-Founder and CTO at Zesty,
where we are focusing on
making cloud really efficient.
And I hope you will actually
be able to take some
actual and practical tips
from this presentation
that you can implement this in your setup.
Let's dive in.
So, when actually it comes
to stability and performance,
it's really easy to solve the problem
by just throwing money
at the problem, right?
We can always take the biggest,
the most powerful instances out there
and just get an amazing
performance at a terrible cost.
On the other hand, if
we squeeze the budget
and we scale down to
the bare, bare minimum
and you know,
and suddenly efficient
becomes unavailable.
So as DevOps engineers
and platform engineers,
our goal is to find a sweet spot.
Our goal is to run complex
production workloads,
they're demanding for resources,
give them just the right infrastructure
and it shouldn't be over-provisioned
or under-provisioned.
And this is a tough
balance to strike, right?
And especially in Kubernetes,
it always means tuning the
configuration to stay efficient,
and it's easier said than done.
So, let's dive in.
Basically one of the best
features in Karpenter,
it's very powerful called
consolidation policies.
What it actually does,
it takes and monitors your nodes
and looking for underutilized nodes
and actually checking if it
can safely terminate them
to save costs
and move the containers somewhere else.
Now, while this sounds
appealing and sounds great,
there are some guardrails
and fine tunings to this behavior
you wanna have in your setup.
Number one is using what's called PDB,
or pod disruption budgets,
it actually controls
and making sure that
not all of your replicas
are being consolidated at the same time.
You wanna make sure that you control
how much replicas Karpenter can interrupt
at any given moment to keep
your setup safe, right?
Another thing is consolidation delays.
You can always configure
how long Karpenter will wait
until it actually goes
and terminate nodes.
And you're setting this
in order for prevent
Karpenter from doing this
during short-term dips in usage,
so it's not gonna go crazy
and interrupt your containers.
So by actually implementing
those controls,
you can avoid consolidation
during your peak,
peak traffic hours.
And you can see an
example configuration here
of how to set this up.
Okay, another important strategy
is to choose the right
instances for your pool.
So it's not just about what's available,
it's about giving the Karpenter
the right amount of flexibility
and give him a set of broader choice.
So you definitely want
to have diversification
because Karpenter actually balances
between cost and availability
and trying to find the instance
that delivers the best
performance at lowest cost.
So in theory, the more
instance types and sizes
you give Karpenter across
different families,
generations and sizes,
so in theory, it can find a better fit,
but you always wanna
avoid extremes, right?
You don't want to include
instances that are too small
because small instances
are causing a lot of network overhead,
they actually adding more complexity
to scheduling and monitoring.
So in this example,
we are actually cutting
out all the tiny flavors,
for example.
But also you don't want
to have too large nodes
because we spoke about
consolidation earlier,
and basically large nodes
that are not fully utilized
is a waste of money, right,
and making the consolidation
less efficient.
So to summarize,
basically all we wanna do is
constantly monitor the behavior
of our cluster,
and it's up to us to define
what's too small or too big
in our exact case.
Another factor that is
constantly overlooked
is DaemonSets.
Basically those are containers
that are running for system services
like monitoring, logging and telemetry
and all of the system stuff
and running per each node.
So when we have larger nodes,
we have small overhead of DaemonSets.
And on the opposite, if
have a lot of small nodes,
it means we have a large
overhead of DaemonSets,
and actually this is consuming resources.
And especially if we're using any software
that is licensed per node,
this can actually silently
inflate your costs,
so take this also as a consideration.
So, let's be honest,
talking about cost savings
without mentioning Spot Instances
probably is not the right thing.
And the good news is that Karpenter
makes management of Spot
Instances really easy.
You just need to allow Spot
Instances in your NodePool
and Karpenter will just take it further,
it will automatically identify Spots
with best price and availability,
take this into account
and choose the right machines
and also take care if they're interrupted
so pods can move somewhere else
and basically provide cost savings.
While this is sounds good,
so let's think where this can fit, right,
where we can use Spot Instances.
And if you ask me,
I think everywhere,
every workload that can
tolerate for interrupts,
whether it's a web server
behind load balancer,
whether it's a stateless microservice,
batch jobs, your dev,
your staging environments,
all of them can recover
quickly from Spot interruptions
and you can leverage
this for cost savings.
So, the best practice here
is actually to configure
Spot Instances with a
failover to on-demand.
And you can see an example
configuration here.
This actually will,
Karpenter in this case will
actually try to provision
a Spot Instance for cost savings,
and if there is no capacity
will transparently move you to on-demand.
So it's a good idea to create
two separate node pools
for Spots and on-demand.
So you can actually use,
you can use node affinity
in your deployments
to configure how much you put to Spot
and how much you keep
on-demand for safety.
And finally, you always need
to keep an eye on fallbacks.
If you have too much fallbacks
and you are falling to
on-demand frequently,
and we spoke about choosing
the right instances,
maybe in this case,
you want to give Karpenter
much broader selection
because you can use instances
that may be not the perfect fit,
but still providing
more than 60% discount,
so it's the right thing to do.
Another strategy would be
using Graviton instances.
As you probably know,
Graviton provides at
least the same performance
or even better for a lower price.
And most of the modern applications
are able to run on ARM
architectures with no code change.
The only investment you have here
is to make sure that
during your CI process
you are building your
dockers both for ARM and x86,
and you have both versions
of the container in your registry.
And Kubernetes will
automatically pick the right one
depends on the node that
this workload is running.
- [Audience member] Okay, no.
- Another thing is actually
it's the last tip for today,
and please use this with caution,
not for production,
but it can really save some costs.
As you probably know,
cross-availability zone
traffic is very expensive,
so for non-production
environment what you can do
is actually you can limit your node pool
to a specific AZ,
and it basically means that
you can enforce data locality
at the infrastructure level.
So, it's actually going
to reduce significantly
the cost of networking.
But again, it's not something
you can do in production,
I don't recommend putting
this stuff in production.
But as you can see here in this example,
we can also configure a failover,
basically use weights and affinity rules
to make sure if there
is a failure of a zone,
we can actually go and
utilize another one.
Okay, so when we spoke about
all of this best practices
and the big question
comes up, "Are we done?"
And the answer is not really.
Basically there is still a
lot of challenges to solve,
and let's mention them.
Kubernetes gives us a lot of metrics,
and it's really hard to
connect them down to costs
in order to identify inefficiencies.
So especially when we
operate large environments
with multiple clusters.
So, we talked about Karpenter a lot,
and even if Karpenter
makes instant decisions
and it's working pretty amazing,
it doesn't mean that the
underlying infrastructure
can keep up because it
takes a lot of time,
it's about couple of minutes
for the infrastructure
to be ready to serve our containers.
And obviously, there are
still operational complexity
to make sure we constantly modify
and adjust our setup to make
it truly, truly efficient.
So basically the question is,
can you afford your teams
to be constantly invested
into making sure your environment
is configured properly?
At the end of the day,
in large environments,
we actually need a continuous automation,
something that will provide
us the ability to be focused
on building rather than optimizing.
And this is exactly where tools
and platforms actually come to assist.
So at Zesty, we developed a
Kubernetes optimization platform
that helps closing those gaps.
Our platform makes,
actually provides you
with the deep visibility
into all of your clusters and containers,
both from usage and
utilization perspective
and making it very easy to
identify inefficiencies.
It uses predictive models
to make scaling decisions
far more efficient.
We execute optimizations
actions automatically on your behalf,
so again, your teams can focus on building
and not optimizing.
So our platform automatically
resize workloads,
both vertically and horizontally,
based on workload's behavior.
It covers not just CPU and memory
but also persistent volumes
for stateful workloads
that are requiring a local storage.
Zesty automatically distributes,
and by the way, we're calling this
a resource optimization layer
that actually goes and
doing active right sizing.
And also we are navigating
and distributing workloads
between Spot Instances
and saving plans to reduce
the expensive on-demand costs.
With our fast scale technology,
basically we maintain a
fleet of hibernated nodes
that are pre-cached
and have all of your
containers and stuff ready
to kick in, in 30 seconds.
And basically this allows
us an instant recovery
from Spot Instance failures
so we can move more
workloads to utilize Spots
without the risk of being interrupted
or having no capacity,
so we call it the financial
optimization layer.
And basically Zesty is the
only platform out there
that combines both resource optimization
and cloud financial optimization practices
to provide at least 70% cost
savings for your clusters.
And if you guys wanna learn more
and hear exactly how we can help
companies achieve efficiency,
our booth is actually located
right here to my right,
so feel free to come say
hi and ask questions.
Thank you so much,
and have a good convention ahead.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)